ladies and gentlemen welcome to the uh
tim dillon show sean mendes is on the
brink
canceling three weeks of shows he's uh
upset
unhappy uh under pressure at a
i think he he tweeted out or put a
message that he is
at his breaking point we uh are upset
we're sad to hear that
he goes uh
i've been touring since i was 15 and to
be honest it's always been difficult to
be on the road away from friends and
family i agree with that statement but
end it when it's on the road
like it's difficult to be on the road
because the benefit of being on the road
is being away from your friends and
family but that's something that like
the publicist goes come here get me
after a few years off the road i felt
like i was ready to dive back in but
that decision was premature and
unfortunately the toll of the road
and the pressure has caught up to me and
i've hit a breaking point after speaking
with my team and health professionals i
need to take some time to heal to take
care of myself
and my mental health first and foremost
as soon as there are more updates i
promise
i will let you know i love you guys and
i'm sure all of his fans are like hey we
love you
don't worry about it
uh you know put yourself first if i
try to move a show a half hour
if i say the show starts at 8 45
people start threatening my life and
screaming and yelling my wife took off
work you know we're [ __ ]
and uh we chose this over her medicine
and uh so i i support sean mendes too
and i hope things work out uh for sean
it's not easy out there um uh god bless
him he's got a lot of money
you know you could always quit
right what's his nat what's sean what is
the net worth of sean mendes just quit
just walk away i'm telling you sean it
it's fine
40 million dollars
you did it
40 million
you're 23.
he's at a breaking point
what what the hell
what are the rest of people at
this is why people hate celebrities
because instead of just saying hey i
don't want to do this
i don't want to do it
i don't want to do it i'm hot i'm rich i
[ __ ] this hot chick
i probably [ __ ] hot dudes you don't know
about perhaps
uh
and i don't want to do it
i don't want to go to mohegan son
i don't want to i thought i would i
don't
but he can't say that he's you know he's
gotta you know but this is why people
hate celebrities because he's got all
this money and he's a you know he said
it's a breaking point and people get
angry about that but um
i understand it
sean mendes
me and you buddy let's stick together
what is this tour called the wonder
world tour
is wonder tour
this was one of the only kids from the
vine era
that became a major
massive
celebrity
the rest of the kids
from the vine era are living in tents
right now on skid row
sucking people off
for money
so that they can just buy
apps
at the app store
that's what these kids are up to
he's got 40 million dollars
um but i get it it is stressful out
there
you know
i'm doing a renovation right now
and
it is
incredibly
trying
i am at a breaking point
i am at a breaking point
with cedar
and
all of these you know i was on a plane
coming back
to los angeles all of these shows these
uh these shows
about you know flip this house and
uh flip or flop with the tarek el moussa
whatever they're all
fake
and all of these shows give you this
idea that you could just flip a house
you could go in there
and
you know switch out a few things
and get everything done on the cheap
turn it around and flip it
right now the cost of anything if
someone comes into your home now
and you just say hey
i i have a gaping hole in my wall can
you fix it
by the after three minutes of talking to
them you go we'll live with it we're
gonna live with it if there are wild
animals
coming at night into your home to kill
your children
and all you need is is a wall patch
after three to five minutes
of speaking to somebody right now
you just go [ __ ] it you know what it's
not that bad we'll live with it it's a
nice breeze because the amount of money
that it costs to get anything done the
materials and you know yes sure these
are luxury problems but that's they're
still problems
and if they're not always luxury
problems some people
some people are having babies and they
need bigger houses because now because
of roe v wade they have to have them so
they have to put on extensions and it's
[ __ ] nuts out there so sean mendes a
toast to you
i raise my glass
to you everything you're going through
being hot
being 23
being amazing looking i know well no
that's not he does anything he feels he
feels differently than he looks he's sad
and i know that
i can intellectualize that i imagine
that it would be empty because the thing
with a kid like shawn mendes you're hot
you're talented you're you're dating
this hot uh camilla but who does he date
i don't even know it's camilla who's he
dating now uh behar
joy baehar who he's dating one of the
hot young starlets uh camilla camilla
cabello so you're commando cabela so you
did look at this guy look at him get
that photo on
get that photo up if you can
get any photo up
there
he's on the brink
don't you get it now
i understand that because you realize
that empty life is when your life is
like that i'm telling you right now this
is not even a joke you actually realize
how vapid and empty
life is and all the things that most
people struggle for in life getting laid
having money looking good
they are challenges that define people's
lives like people losing 20 pounds is a
challenge that defines people's entire
life on earth
they spend their entire life trying to
lose 30 pounds
to be a little less fat that's the
entire arc of their entire life
and shawn mendes is just gorgeous
and he's rich now he's got 40 million
dollars people spend their entire life
struggling to put fifty thousand 000
in a retirement account so they can get
a little like barn thing
he already at 23 years old has 40
million dollars he's already hot he's
already got the girl he's already
famous
there's not much left to do there's
nowhere to go
so that's why he's at a breaking point
because we haven't invented
interplanetary travel
he can't he's already at 23 years old
done it
there's nothing left on this planet for
him to do
really
so unless he goes to mars
there's nothing more he can do so people
go oh like well i'm not making fun of
him
it's simply interesting
to note what happens to people
who are
so incredibly successful at a young age
that there's nowhere for them to go
i understand what he means i am 14 years
old
what i have done
with this show
bailing him out of the mess of his life
giving him and his family a reason to
live
just because they say they know me
giving my own family uh a a a a purpose
because they now walk around with their
head held high
at 14 years old i will be dead by 20
because what else can i do how can i
reach the next level it's impossible
won't happen
it won't happen i've done it i've done
it
so many times over
at a young age
that
it's not possible for me to find
fulfillment do you get it do you
understand
me sean mendes people like us
who've lapped you so many times in every
conceivable
metric of life
me and shawn mendes
when guys like me and shawn mendes sit
around
we look at you people as if you are uh
like some type of
flesh-eating bacteria
that lives on a log
or in some lake
we look at you like a necrotizing for
shyness like you're alive
but
for no good reason and to no good end
and
people like me and shawn mendes struggle
greatly with meaning in life because we
have done it
in a way that is so
incredible
you know um
and that's why we've become very close
friends
me and tron mendez we spend a lot of our
time together i was the one who told him
to cancel this tour
because i said
you have to start thinking about you
um
[Music]
and this is why people like him
within four or five years
will be there's two things he'll get
back on the horse he'll become some type
of musical legend
maybe he'll be an actor or he will join
a cult
you know there there's there's very few
places to go
unless he really just like drops out and
quietly goes to a suburb is rich
and just opens up like uh you know i
don't know
like a little restaurant invest in a
franchise because there's nowhere to go
he's at the top
he's at the pinnacle
there's nowhere to really go what do you
suggest if shawn mendes is your friend
and shawn mendes comes to you and goes
i'm at the breaking point i simply can't
do it anymore what do you do what do you
tell him what is your actual advice this
is tough because so many mental health
uh people have advised him already but i
would say what are they saying what is
the mental health community saying right
here they're saying uh what are they
saying he consulted health care
professionals in his team before
deciding he needed to take some time to
heal and take care of myself and my
mental health so they told him to that
he's he's like elvis he's he's
overworked he's over i just imagine my
agent
um
i imagine going to my agent going listen
i'm having a lot of
mental issues i'm at the breaking point
um
my agent i've had covered my agents like
just lie about it and go out there and
perform
okay
the co my agent right now is terrified
because they are
the ukraine which is the bread basket of
europe
is
as a food producer as a grain producer
is struggling
my agent consumes 15 loaves of bread a
day
and wholesale
he is terrified
having me go out and perform is so
important for him uh and his family
that
[Applause]
i it doesn't matter what i had like i've
literally had covert he's like just lie
and he goes no it'll check just go do it
who cares
so i could only imagine if i came to him
and said you know i'm at the breaking
point he's like well
i understand that but how about reno
nevada
you know what'll get you out of that
do you know there was one member of
shawn mendes's team who was like
listen sean we all think we know what we
want
we think we want peace and quiet but you
know what we actually want the hordes
are screaming ticket holding fans
that's what we really want
we could all say that we want the love
of
a friend or a family member
but you know what we really want
we want to hear
the merch numbers at the end of the
night
how many of those girls bought hoodies
that's what we really need like you know
there's one scumbag
on mendez see i don't have a team i have
one agent who weighs as much as a team
but
sean mendes has an actual team
of people who advise him
um
you know but good for him i mean you
know god bless
ray khan is the company raycon's
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever with optimized gel tips
for the perfect in-ear fit these earbuds
are so comfortable and they will not
budge trust me they stay in
have you ever done these raycon earbuds
they're great they're better they are
dude they're so much cheaper than the
other name brand earbuds trust me
they offer three sound profiles to match
what you're listening to plus noise
isolation awareness mode so you can
choose to be immersed in sound to or to
be able to hear your surroundings like
when you're jogging you want to hear the
surround because the car comes and it ah
raycons give you eight hours of play
time to 32 hour battery life then when
you need to charge it's super easy you
can even do it wirelessly and this is a
huge selling point with recons you get
the same quality audio as the other
premium audio brands but at half the
price yes really but that doesn't mean
they won't last i've seen people talking
about their raycons falling three
stories getting lost in the rain and
snowstorms and still working afterwards
it's no wonder raycon's everyday earbuds
have over 49 000 five-star reviews buy
the raycons
check out raycon's wireless earbuds my
guess is that you're going to want to
leave them for a five-star review go to
buy raycon.com
tim today to get your 15 off your raycon
order that's by raycon.com tim to score
15 off by raycon.com
tim
everybody right now is dealing with all
kinds of stress and the way to handle it
is better help online therapy i'm
telling you it is a great way to support
a healthy brain okay how we care for our
minds affects how we experience life so
it's important to invest time and care
into keeping ourselves healthy
better help us online therapy it offers
video phone and even live chat only
therapy sessions so if you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's so much more affordable than
in-person therapy you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours our
listeners are getting 10 off their first
month is that true yeah they get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.comtimd that's
betterhelp.comd i mean that seems
unbelievable i used it myself do you
believe that yeah i used it i signed up
i got the what do you tell them my boss
is horrible
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com that's
betterhlp.com
tim d i'm telling you you won't regret
it you'll never regret what you do for
your mental health this is something
that's always been said and i've agreed
with you got to go into the world
already and and and readiness is
important what do they say about luck
it's preparation and you ready whatev
the point is that you got to be on your
tippy toes you know or on the tips here
and that's what happens when you get
therapy online
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.comd that's better
atlp.comd
gavin newsom uh is thinking of running
for the president of the united states
he is the most uh one of the most hated
politicians from the most hated state in
the union gavin newsom has now released
an ad
that says that he is going to try or
planning potentially
to be a contender and you know
biden's senile and a corpse kamal is
incredibly unpopular hillary uh too old
unpopular there aren't many options for
the democrats right the republicans have
desantis
seemingly maybe trump probably desantis
gavin newsom definitely seems to be
um
now the original version of this ad by
the way
um
and which is good which is why they
had drag queens twerking and then
eight-year-olds just making it rain on
them
that was the original version of the ed
um and it was they had it in uh it was
set right on
the universal lot we're proud of that
in california universal studios and and
it's just eight nine year olds just
making it rain
on on the drag queens and the drag
queens are just twerking with their g
strings up and then gavin newsom
stands in the middle
and he goes you're gonna pay for gas
[ __ ]
and then all the drag queens go yes
daddy
and then they start whipping him with a
leather thing and then it says gavin
knew some
hey america how about this and this is a
question mark
um
that's the was the original ad they ran
that in focus groups now people got
really testy
about that kevin newsom didn't
understand why he said it was a drag
queen birthday party what's the big deal
it was a normal california drag birthday
party and
with some leather daddy bdsm
uh climate uh uh content appropriate
climate content where you know
because gavin says listen the reality of
the situation is
uh you know and it's like it's like
we're saving the planet
um
and i'm not even kidding like
the original slogan that they were
testing again and i'm not folks people
get so mad at me when i report the news
i don't i barely give opinions on these
things
gavin newsom's campaign ad
that slogan that they were testing was
we're gonna save the planet
for child drag queens
and and and it was just child dragged
children in drag
and
and gavin because this is the future
now
i
that slogan did horribly when it was
tested
so now they've now they have this where
he's i don't he's standing in a yard
that's meant to look like by the way
landscaping on this yard now that i know
you look at it
around 20 to 30k
just on the landscaping around but he's
trying to like appeal to people and seem
like he's gavin newsom as the great ray
comp and me have said many times is in
effete wine merchant what that means
is that he has a estate in northern
california where he wanders around in a
robe and drinks like barolo
drinking red wine he's never been to los
angeles he doesn't know what it is
because in his words latinos are
confusing he goes not good or bad but i
don't know who's who this is what he
said to his wife
now
so which by the way he was married to
that kimberly guilfoyle newsome who's
now married to uh donald trump jr
because one thing she likes is authentic
connections she she's in it for love
kimberly guilfoyle newsome first wife
and so was he he wanted that big kidded
monster too so see he
he's not how do you let him off right he
knew what was going on so gavin newsom
now is um
what they're doing now in california is
if you have a birthday party for your
children there have to be drag queens
there that is a requirement in
california
at least one
at least one drag queen
at the party
um
that's it's a requirement let's play now
of course we're kidding around here i
don't think that's a law yet
um
keep the kids out of the bars i've said
it before
gay people should be a little more
should be more vocal on this it
shouldn't only be like right-wing
christian types that say this it is
incredibly inappropriate for any
children to be throwing money at a drag
queen or a stripper or children
stripping themselves children should be
left alone to figure out who they are
uh and that's the position of
sane people okay
except in the state of california
because kids in the state of california
are advanced so
if they want to twerk on their birthday
they should be allowed to there's a lot
of kids that go to their parents and say
listen
i want this to be a 70s style bath house
for my birthday can i do bath house
and
theme
parents have to and the parents are
straight of course but they're they are
you know they have virtue so they go
well and they talk about it they go hey
mike yeah
we're gonna do pizza party but you know
some of the kids are
they have gluten insensitivities so
that's going to be tough so our son mike
wants to do 70s bath house theme
which you know would mean that all the
kids and the parents you know rent out
like a bath house and everybody goes in
and like simulate the conditions of an
orgy
but not have them
but like show
people that it's like okay and fun so
they want to do bath house and like
glory holes but the cupcakes go through
this is
um
so here is this is what i mean it's like
let the kids
figure out who they are
there's zero reason for a kid to really
be in a bar i used to watch my father
play music in a bar my family would
bring me in
and i'd stand there and watch that near
do well
uh strum a guitar and he was very good
at it you know and he you know used to
play with this guy gary and gary was on
the
uh you know the keyboards of the synth
and my father was on the guitar and i
was like a young kid and i'd go watch
him play music instead of um raise me
and it was uh
bad for for me
it's actually bad for me
i shouldn't have been there so i just
think kids should be left alone and i i
i it's handing
its handing
christian looney tunes
an issue
it's going
here you go
here's your issue
if you want freedom
if you want
you know women to be able to
have abortions during a reasonable
window
if you want uh people to be able to
marry who they want if you want society
to kind of progress
in a way that doesn't completely abandon
morality
and judgment you cannot have children i
don't know who is doing this
who is doing this
now certain
certain things are okay
certain
kids my friend
is doing it uh her daughter
they're doing
dikes on bikes for the kids
where all the kids are gonna get on
motorcycles with lesbians and ride out
into the desert
that's fine
because lesbians don't have sex
it's not sexual at all
lesbians are just creatures
from an ancient past chupacabras
so there's nothing sexual about that so
there's nothing wrong with the kids
getting on the motor because the kids
are on the motorcycles and they go out
to the desert with the dykes fine
fine
um
here's another thing which i don't know
if i love
friend of mine
his four-year-old they're doing a
rent-themed birthday
the show rent
well i'm all for broadway
but
the kids are gonna each pick a character
from rent someone's gonna be the heroin
addict who does anal me
someone's gonna be uh the transgender
person angel who has aids
someone's gonna be mark
who has aids someone's gonna be adam who
has aids
someone's gonna be the black guy i
forget his name he sings santa fe which
i love let's open up a restaurant in
santa fe
what a great song
uh
collins i forget his name don't look it
up the point is
you're doing it's a four-year-old
right and because the four-year-old said
to the parents he came to the parents
and said can we do a rent-themed party
where everyone pretends to have aids
um
so i don't know how i feel about that
but
i don't think it's the worst idea
if all the kids can know that they don't
have aids
drag queens you know for the most part
it's like adult entertainment you know
we should have adult entertainment in
america and drag queens you know i think
the fun of drag is that they are acerbic
and witty and they say things that are
inappropriate and usually it's late at
night and they're funny and sexual in
certain instances not always drag
inherently isn't sexual it's kind of
buffoonish and clownish but there are
moments of it that are certainly
inappropriate for kids
um i also think drag queens you know
they're inappropriate they're fun they
do
lowbrow racial ethnic humor
i've always seen that i think it's great
um i don't think that pc drag queens i
mean what a hellish nightmare drag
queens reading books at libra who wants
to read books to kids at like can you
imagine if we had to do that like every
sunday we had to go
read
books to these illiterate junkies
in this country
let's watch this this gavin newsom's
going to be the president now yeah and
he's airing this in florida gavin
newsom's airing it in these swings him
and desantis are going they're going hog
wild
by the way florida parties for the kids
they're doing and i and here again you
might not like it
my friend lives in florida i'm not even
kidding
he said we're doing a party and it's
called it is the theme of the party is
parkland but the kids win this time
so the theme of the party is parkland
but the kids win so the kids get
guns that are not loaded we hope
and the job of the kids they run around
and
a kid comes in
and they point at them they go look at
that anti-social communist and then they
get them
before he gets them
gavin news from the president
it's independence day oh let's talk
about what's going on in america freedom
it's under attack in your state
republican leaders they're banning books
making it harder to vote restricting
speech in classrooms even criminalizing
women and doctors i urge all of you
living in florida by the way join the
fight i mean i'm so pr i'm a pro-choice
guy but i just love the idea of
criminalizing women
and i'm wondering can i can i
criminalize women while still being
pro-choice
like is there a way
to criminalize women
while letting them have abortions
because that fascinates me that hits me
right in the political sweet spot if
there ever was one
if there ever was a way to really speak
to tim dillon it's remaining kind of
libertarian-minded
and allowing people to have freedoms but
also finding a way to criminalize women
the just that coupling of words makes me
uh get out the checkbook
and donate i don't know how that's being
done but just just women starting as
criminals and then having to prove
they're not
i like that idea
much like how people are born with
original sin
uh women being criminals first and then
so what's he say let's let's finish this
up here join the fight with gavin newsom
or join us in california but we still
believe in freedom doesn't look like
that by the way go back to that freedom
back to that
nothing
nothing looks like what they
they it right there no state let me tell
you right now
i just returned from the greatest state
that god ever gave man new york
uh where we have the hamptons
which is a beautiful
community it's stunningly
it's breathtaking
um
so many different types of white people
on pills
you know what i mean like so many
different types of like this long white
stare like kind of like
you have this yeah
and you have the surfer which is a
little more like
but
a couple of women there on the pills
get off the bagels ladies because you
know in the hamptons the women have to
and i have a friend there who's managing
my home there she's a fatty bombati
and the women uh
aren't kind to her because of that
uh a fat uh rotund pink cherubic man in
the hamptons is treated as he should be
like a god who fell from the clouds
because he might have a lot of money
but uh the young mommies do not like big
ladies
they don't
like it
um and i was just there and it's pretty
and it holds up new york city holds up
when you go
you go i've seen it on a bunch of films
this is kind of what it looks like when
you go to california there's uh there's
some type of like wait what
wait huh
there's very few places that hold up
some up north big sur that area fine
beverly hills of course is beverly hills
but the vast majority of california is
it just does not present as you would
think it does it has done a great hood
wink california is you know
it's a it's a dating profile
you know that's a little misleading
for sure
not a straight-up catfish but like where
you go oh god
like when you see the person at the
table you know this feeling you're
walking to the coffee table and you see
the person
from about
let's say 10 meters away and your first
response is i hope to god this isn't
what it is and you know down deep that
it is and you have to sit down with them
anyway
um while they like you know eat their
coffee they like chew it
um
i was talking to raycomp earlier peter
schiff is in trouble now they're trying
to get him
for his bank i don't know why he's
running a bank
leadership's running a puerto rican bank
but you know
people do what they do and we support
schiff never support the feds never
support the feds
peter schiff owns a bank with jake paul
who cares so what
so what it's nice to have a bank why
don't you get a bank
they're mad at him because they said
he's capital requirements he doesn't
have any money in the bank
stop this i don't know i don't know
enough about it to even go into it i
don't know enough about it we want to
try to get him on the show let's get him
on the show he's
he's he's on he's intro they're trying
to get him
um
so let's let's watch this by the way
because by the way just get can you
freeze on the picture of santa monica
uh was that right before this yeah yeah
so freeze in here okay okay
i don't know what year
this was taken
look how far away you are by the way
this is kind of funny and interesting
look how far away you are this is
essentially an aerial
shot
of california this is where california
still can look somewhat desirable from
the air
this is so far away
from anything
um
now i just want you to google in another
tab
santa monica homeless because santa
monica is one of the scariest places
you'll ever go
i was there the other day and the people
just walk around screaming at the sun
like cursing god
i mean
yeah any photo unimport
so that that's up close
what santa monica looks like that's the
same area that's the same area that
you're looking at from the aerial shot
um
[Music]
yeah it's the same one right there there
it is that's what it looks like up close
okay
endless tent cities now go to the area
oh yeah isn't that pretty
that looks pretty so what again it's a
trick of hollywood they're lying
to you they are making it seem like
california is an idyllic paradise when
in fact it is not
the only thing that
is do also the rest of the country is
also a dump
so unless you can live in like jackson
hole palm beach
east hampton
like there's like 10 places in the
country that aren't a complete dump so
that's that's a benefit to california
um
[Music]
watch let's watch the rest of this ad
but we still believe in freedom freedom
of speech no you don't listen freedom
not only do you not believe in freedom
this state is not free
they take all of your money you don't
get to uh i mean the vaccine thing they
went nuts
lockdowns they they absolutely don't
believe in free it's so
you know why why not just honest
political ads
why not just honest political ads no i
mean they look genuinely where they stop
cut this [ __ ] about like well if
we're free and then your state they
don't like free and it's like what do
you want
what do you want
like like literally it's a guy like
[ __ ] newsome going looking at you and
going what do you care about and who do
you want to see killed
do you agree with us you like what we
like you want to kill the people we want
to kill or the other way around
because that's all it is
what do you like which natural disasters
do you like and who do you disagree with
uh on a level where if they were a
victim of a natural disaster you'd say
good
that's real political ads it's none of
this [ __ ]
about this
this beautiful uh mixed race family by
the way
this is um
freedom from hate
and the freedom to love
so you have a mixed race family here
it's the freedom to hate and the freedom
from love
okay
that family which i don't know if it's
real or not
okay
each of them has to work 19 hours a day
to afford their 19 000 mortgage
in this state so there's not a lot of
freedom left after you've worked every
hour that you're alive
and there's not a lot of freedom to
raise your children unless you can
afford
you know
to really have the time to be with them
that's the other issue they don't want
to talk about how unaffordable
california is
keep going
hate and the freedom to love don't let
them take your freedom paid for by
newsome for california governor 2022.
yeah i mean listen it's not it's it's
not that uh it's it's not uh god what is
this here oh god uh i think this is that
gary chambers guy i don't know what he's
i can't i don't have anything for him so
let's just move on
bars guy
great whatever that means god bless him
yeah he's democrat from louisiana
running for the senate good for him i
don't know what anything means anymore
um
he does a campaign and where he burns a
confederate flag okay cool cool
hey man my best to you
uh but everywhere is a dump right
florida's a dump outside of a few places
so i mean you know what are you gonna do
your brothers hit homeless you're
getting bad in dallas yeah he said
they're gonna get bad everywhere i know
that it's fun to hit california over the
head because they have crazy policies
and they've brought this on themselves
encouraged it some of it's the climate
but homelessness is gonna get bad
everywhere for the simple fact that um
drugs are becoming the only thing that
work uh to alleviate the uh hellscape
we've created
yeah i mean those are the only things
that work right so drugs drugs tend to
work very well
um
the problem is they have a lot of
unintended consequences that knock
people
uh
down a few pegs in life and
unfortunately it's hard to climb out of
that hole
ordering all your summer essentials with
dash pass by doordash is a great way to
get everything you need
and during the summer of dash pass you
can save money and access members only
offers it will help you feel easy and
breezy all season long i use doordash so
i just switched to this summer is in
full spring and the celebration begins
during the summer of dash pass by
doordash okay weekly members only offers
and new items released every week so you
can shine bright and feel cool all
season long do you order from doordash
but wish you didn't have to pay delivery
fees well dreams come true during the
summer of dash pass you can save money
and enjoy new membership only offers
every week on top of zero delivery fees
all year round
you join this club you have no delivery
fees they give you exclusive offers it's
great okay there's more than 25 000
members only offers nationwide dash pass
by doordash has everything you need to
make your summer memorable
here's what i'm noticing right now
traffic everywhere you go there's
traffic all these people are in their
cars they're honking the kids to
screaming the bats the dogs the militias
everybody's out
what do you do well here's what you do
you get the dash pass you have your
dasher go deal with that traffic so you
don't have to and with dash pass you
know you're getting a great deal you're
being charged zero delivery fees it is
so much oh you need catch up you press a
button on your phone it shows up it's
worth it you can never get that hour of
your life back
shine bright like a diamond
shine bright during daw dash summer of
dance pass shine bright during daw dash
they pay me extra if i do that shine
bright during da dash
uh
your first order up to 15 so so by the
way here's what they're saying now and
this is crazy shine bright shine bad
during da dash summer of dash pass you
get 15 50 off your first order in a 15
value choose promo code tim dillon to
check out when you spend 12 or more so
if you order up to 15 7.50 of that half
of that is on the house
50 of your first order up to 15 value
when you sign up for doordash during the
summer of dashmaster using promo code
tim dillon don't forget the code tim
dillon for the first fifty dollars off
your order
shine bright
don't forget that's good tim dillon for
50 off your first order up to 15 value
dash pass benefits only on eligible
orders that meet the minimum subtotal
terms apply
simply safe is very important right now
security we all got to take security
seriously we believe home should be the
safest place on earth for every family
that's why using recommend simply safe
simply safe is advanced whole
home security that puts you your home
and your family safety first here's why
i love it they offer comprehensive
protection not only against intruders
and burglary but against expensive home
hazards from flooding to fires okay
because you might be careless or
somebody else might be careless in your
home
with 24 7 professional monitoring simply
save agents take action the moment a
threat is detected dispatching police or
first responders in an emergency even if
you're not home simply safe uses
proprietary video verification
technology so that monitoring agents can
visually confirm the threat in order to
get higher priority 9-1-1 dispatch
monitoring plans are affordably priced
and one dollar a day with no long-term
contract or hidden fees because feeling
safe at home should not break the bank
you can customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes at
simplisafe.com tim dillon go today and
claim a free indoor security camera plus
20 off with interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.com tim dillon that's simply
safe s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash tim dillon and save 20 off
with interactive monitoring
uh i installed this at my house by the
way my mother was so happy she's like uh
i'm glad you got a security system
finally right yeah i installed it at my
place and i'm uh i'm so excited about it
and i'm very happy and it's worked so
far no one's i'm here
hard to climb out of the hole i wanted
to watch a little bit somebody sent me
this six years ago they did like this
very weird and rt covered at this very
strange
um
ceremony for the opening of a tunnel in
switzerland
and it really did you know you know
obviously a lot of people send you
things you go oh it's an illuminati
ritual it's an illuminati ritual
and a lot of it's you know hokum
a lot of it's you know crazy and there's
they're making this big stretch it's a
leap it's a jump
uh not not so much here because this one
isn't incredibly disturbing
and hilarious
by the way so
people from switzerland are just
terrifying
uh can we see that on the screen
so
by the way so
and i i don't know if this has been
covered a bunch maybe it has been
somebody just sent this to me
um
you know what's amazing about all this
this is an opening of like a tunnel it's
completely
like unnecessary it could it could have
been like a ribbon cutting ceremony just
a real plain
you know basically something that's
ignored but instead they do this crazy
hour-long ceremony where they have like
baomat
dancing around like guys and goats heads
and everything play a little bit of this
ben and then play play some of the
uh you know um
uh what you may call it uh what are they
called when you save something in a a
minute time stamp yeah some of them were
disturbing time stamps here they're just
it's it's it's really funny it's so long
yeah okay i'll just start at the
beginning here because this is just and
the music's insane too
yeah
and this is at a obviously a faster
speed yeah yeah i'm gonna should i just
leave it on faster i guess yeah yeah
this is just how it starts right here
cloud schwab was like we're going all
the way this time
we don't give a [ __ ]
klaus schwab's like every now and then
we just go hard yeah you know every now
and then we just got to go hard like
sometimes get go go to some more of the
other stuff yeah this stuff right here
yeah
opening of a tunnel
slow this down okay
this is really like
where you just go oh
this is insane
[Music]
can you like imagine
i mean these are the guys in hostile in
the movie hostel who drill through the
girl's eye yeah and they're just sitting
there and they're watching this
i mean this is one of the most insane
things i've ever seen in my life
[Music]
[Music]
this is the uh
this is the jizzling maxwell memorial
service
he's yodeling this is the yodeling
pedophile
this is d
this is the yodeling pedophile
a uh character from swiss uh mythology
okay so once they then they have the
pope there's a whole thing but the pope
comes yeah the pope
uh very popular the pope makes a cameo
for the opening of a tunnel i mean what
what is going on here
why
why is the pope
what is the pope doing here
this is like these guys have these weird
bird cages like on their heads
i mean this this whole thing's weird
and then uh
this is as they're moving outside then
the pope comes in at like some point is
your children like dressed as angels
yeah there's the pope you can see him on
the car is that the real pope no not the
real one oh that's not the real post no
no i don't know it's a fake pope there
he is
oh that's not the pope that's clown
schwab
okay so once they get outside uh so i'm
gonna go to 3420 here this gets a little
nuts right here so they're climbing this
they're pretending to climb this rock
wall and that's right falling and dying
and now they're all naked yeah and then
they all uh this robe here
these dudes are hung is this the way
switzerland's doing it jesus
i didn't know swiss had huge dicks
so now
i i guess this is uh and they're all in
the dust here and i have no idea what's
going on can you imagine
if you were just like yeah we're going
to some ribbon cutting ceremony okay
here we go now we got the creepy nuns
yeah yeah
here we go this is i mean this is this
is an a24 movie
here we go
this is worse than a24 this is by the
way it's better than an 824 movie let's
be let's be honest
hereditary was [ __ ]
they found some creepy girl
that's all hereditary was they just
found this
girl that you know
face looked like a tuna sandwich
i mean is i mean
you know some of the illuminati people
are sitting there going okay this is too
much
we went too far here
they were like we said
we wanted notes of this
we said let's touch on the themes
lightly
uh we were supposed to touch on the
themes of enslaving the human race
lightly
this is a bit heavy-handed
no
what do you mean i'm doing exactly what
you asked
you have people in bug costumes
you don't think this is a bit
heavy-handed
okay keep going this is crazy okay so
this is the uh this part this is they're
kind of gearing up for the finale here
right
so here comes the uh the goat the goat
makes a
comes back here
[Music]
yeah i mean i it's just
really confusing
[Music]
how many views does this have is this
something that's like known do people
know about this
this has
only seven hundred thousand views from
six years ago yeah
yeah
yeah this is you know and then uh so
then the finale here is the goat lady it
looks like and this is the most watched
part the most replayed yeah this one
here yeah right here this is like a
mural from the denver airport came to
life
[Music]
you're right though it's kind of like
mid-summer almost it's it's
well this is our whole thing now you
have like a
goat who's
looks like a trans goat
and then i'm just gonna skip to the
finale here because that part here's the
positive there's two possibilities here
number one this is 100 an illuminati
production number two
really america is the only country that
should ever make like any type of
artistic music or anything like this is
like if this is what they do if this
wasn't directed
by like bilderberg child eating serpents
that's even more disturbing like if this
is just what
they thought would be good
if this is them we've got a bigger
problem
oh yeah so this is the finale i think
the whole thing they're trying to say
like time is god so they're like they
show the clock there
you see this clock
they're all seeing it count down because
it saves so much time because they can
go through the swiss outlet they could
go through the tunnel yeah
right so
yeah who can go through the tunnel yeah
so it's like time is god and then it
goes crazy
and then this is the big uh hurrah at
the end you see the the
you can see it go out of the tunnel here
[Music]
that's the train of two children
be sacrificed
[Music]
[Applause]
i like one of them was doing a fortnight
dance yeah you see that one of them was
doing a fortnight i mean you see man
you just can't keep us out of anything
we'll invade even the illuminati ritual
with our [ __ ]
we just pop up all right well that was
nice
that tunnel right there the gothard
tunnel
someone who you know who sends me a lot
of things and won't say who okay i i
know who you're talking sent me that and
i thought that was interesting and i
watched it and now we've played it on
the show
my
friend
the poet laureate of this country the
great steve will do it a man who
doesn't say much does he talk really
like on the podcast does he say anything
not much it's more an accident sometimes
he talks right yeah what does he say he
sheepishly grins a lot
get something up he's done okay here's
uh his man cave he has a man cave now
steve don't flag our video paige all
right boys i wanna i'll hear you is he
speaking people do it video and i wanna
say i love you guys so much right now he
loves everybody all the time this guy 22
ranger and i bought it for father's day
and i was gonna give it to the
firefighter but he needed cold hard cash
so i am giving this to somebody that
likes this video and subscribes to wow
steve that's cool i'll give it away next
week subscribe to life so by the way
folks this is why you got to support
this guy because you might get a car
not only is he funny and interesting and
the videos they make are always worth
watching because they're insane
but um
like they like put metal dinosaurs in
their house and throw them off the roof
and stuff whatever the thing is they
kill people sometimes but it's all for
but look at what they're doing they give
people a ford explorer
so here's what we this guy got big just
drinking like you know bottles of
alcohol and not dying and now he's like
one of the biggest celebrities on the
internet and he's actually realizing
that with great power comes great
responsibility that's something i came
up with in my head and that he
is now helping a lot of people he's
giving
like degenerate gamblers who lost their
children one last chance
to subscribe to a webs a website that's
only operational outside of america and
you know because here's the deal if
you're a degenerate gambler you're gonna
win eventually you know what i mean
that's the thing about winning it's
gonna happen so what he's trying to do
is he goes to people that have had
issues and he tries to help them by
giving them another shot to you know
bet uh some ethereum on a college ball
game or something
and there's something nice about that he
also finds kids with cancer all over the
place i don't know how he does is there
a booker
is there an agent who's identifying all
these kids that are immediately going to
die so that this guy could look like a
good person can i get a few baldies can
i get a few bald kids here make me look
better anyway
whoever's people are good because they
keep dragging these dead beats and these
bald head cancer kids so this guy can be
a good person um
we do love him steve will do it he's uh
so what is this what is this channel
steve will do it steve will do it and he
also has the uh that one the life of
steve the life of steve and i think you
guys should subscribe to it because
let's just go to and then look at this i
i gave a kid with cancer the most epic
day go to this that's awesome how
[ __ ] cool is this that's really cool
this is great what is this anything you
see on what's the most epic day
[Music]
here we go the style sir let's make
happy that the are they getting the kid
drunk with cancer
get him [ __ ] up
fine to find a store or bar like is he
getting the kid a hooker
and boys tag us in your stories on you
know nothing cures leukemia like [ __ ]
you must be 21 plus to buy and drink
happy dad okay well they're not
advertising on our show but they got a
free ad now
you better call shahidi
and what is he doing
is that the kid we can't can we get to
the cancer kid please these videos like
45 minutes
oh here we go what's up dude am i the
only black kid here like where's celine
what's the
difference you are the only black kid
here
your leg looks awesome
damn you [ __ ] he looks fine
the kid's fine
oh there's a girl okay
good for him
[Music]
so now what does he do for the kids okay
let's fast forward and see what he does
for them all right nice to meet you
let's see so been in the helicopter
oh he takes him into a helicopter
oh he's buying him draft nice
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
and you know what's good about this by
the way after they die the clothes all
go right back
i actually no he's actually a good guy
we do like steve he's doing really good
stuff this is what people on the
internet with money should do take these
kids out and have fun i mean can we do
that i mean
right we tried with the guy muscular
dystrophy he's a fun guy but then his
nerves started smoking crack and
everything
i mean nothing we try to do works
um
no steve is legitimately a good person
and and this is really good and this is
really good to think so good to see go
to steve will do it on youtube he's got
almost five million subscribers hit him
again and uh these are his channels the
israelis channels now happy dad full
senpai yeah but we're just plugging
steve's
so steve will do it he's one of our
favorites
he paid me in a depreciating asset to do
this
um which i appreciate but it's coming
back right winklevosses get them with a
[ __ ] phone uh oh it is coming back a
little bit it's 21. jesus christ
anyway um thank you folks
how about that
timdalecomedy.com where will i be i'm
going to be at the san jose improv um
january uh july 28th
29th and the 30th
that is where i'll be we have five shows
tickets are selling out on august 7th
i'm going to be at the west hampton
beach pack performing arts center with
ben avery and ray comp we're doing a
live podcast in long island
um
thursday august 11th the 12th and the
13th i'm going to be in salt lake city
utah
and uh
we're we're gonna be at wise guys one of
my favorite clubs wise guys comedy club
doing some stand-up comedy so if you
want to grab tickets to san jose or salt
lake that's awesome also west hampton
pack we're doing a live podcast in the
summer
in long island tim dillon comedy.com you
can grab tickets uh
we will also be um
releasing some merch eventually not
immediately but it's coming a lot of
people ask for some new fake business
stuff and things like that
um we also have uh
some other things being worked on we can
say we're going to the specials going to
be out on netflix sometime in august
they have paid me
a pittance of money a very small amount
that barely covers the shooting of it
um but they are in trouble they're in
big trouble
and they are now uh
playing ball a little bit they haven't
you know they're going to put it on as
is without any content notes really so
uh that is cool so it'll be up there if
you wanna watch we also have um
more things happening all the time uh
which is phenomenal
lots of ideas kicking around don't know
which ones uh make the cut and which
ones don't
um but we do have uh
interesting things in the works correct
yes oh yeah yeah
working on a book right now
uh tentatively titled the boomer guide
to parenting
uh some funny stories about my parents
want to kind of release it before they
both die
kind of get back at them just petty
vindictive
book where i just settle scores with
dead people some of the people i'm
talking about are dead in the book
but settling scores with dead people
louis ck told me that should be the
subtitle of the book settling scores
with dead people that's great
not a bad idea not the worst idea um in
california for a bit back east uh thanks
thanks to all of our friends at gas
digital for letting us use that studio
when we are in new york the great lewis
gomez ralph sutton bobby hutch and
others support all the things on gas
digital if you can they are a podcast
network where i and many other podcasts
have gotten their start and they're good
friends of ours and we appreciate that
and this is their uh website right here
gasdigitalnetwork.com
and they have a lot of great shows
legitimate skanks
sdr real ass podcast louis j gomez
[Music]
and others aaron burgs on there a lot of
people so check that out if you
can and we will see you either next week
or we'll see you on patreon every
thursday good night